vous y voyez plutôt comme d'autres vous
n'êtes pas le seul une l'effet d'une
domination les hommes ayant dominé les
femmes pendant suffisamment longtemps et
encore très récemment et vous voyez
d'ailleurs vous vous reconnaissez d'une
certaine manière vous reconnaissez votre
votre votre éducation
on vous a élevé de cette manière là
dites vous quand vous lisiez les
témoignages de femmes qui sur mis tous
disaient disait avoir été victime de
harcèlement d'agressions de viol même
vision au fond vous reconnaissiez
l'éducation viril qui a été celle des
hommes pendant des centaines et des
centaines de générations
une chose qui est quand même importante
à dire c'est que vous allez remarquer
dans ce que vous avez dit vous avez dit
bon les femmes ou une importance dans
l'intimité c'est bien fait et où même
dans le dal dans le rôle qu'elles ont pu
avoir vis-à-vis des hommes finalement
donc c'est comme si leur fonction est
toujours une fonction par procuration
c'est pour ça que j'ai évoqué cette idée
de passivité et d'activités c'est à dire
que les femmes sont toujours délégué en
quelque sorte des hommes et c'est ça qui
fait le le le coeur de la domination
dans son fonctionnement dans son
fonctionnement politique ensuite lorsque
je parle de domination je ne veux pas
dire que c'est une domination comment
dire c'est à dire que cette domination
elle résulte d'une fragilité originaire
qui est plus une fragilité des hommes
eux mêmes dont on parlera peut-être
parce qu'il faut essayer de comprendre
d'où ça vient
cette espèce de déséquilibre originel
qui se traduit par cette domination mais
je voudrais quand même précisé que si
nous sommes dans cette situation
aujourd'hui
à mon sens c'est parce qu'il ya une
grande déclaration qui est la
déclaration du xviiie siècle la
déclaration de la modernité au xviiie
siècle c'est pas la post modernité
moi je crois pas d'ailleurs à l'idée de
postmodernité je crois que modernité ça
veut dire multiplier multiplication des
modes de vie dans un même espace protégé
par le droit sans prendre position sur
ce que doivent être les individus donc
on n'est pas dans la post modernité
puisque la modernité elle n'est pas
dépassable finalement dire que c'est
juste une accélération de ce processus
de multiplication l'axé c'est ça que
j'ai fini gilles lipovetsky zenatti la
suit et ses listes
miss me de la modernité dont on est dear
god oh pardon une accélération de la
modernité pour la post modernité c'est
précisément ceci débat surgit lipovetsky
mais justement je me je me suis d'accord
dit avec j'ai dis pas qu'il n'y avait
que jean françois lyotard sur cette
question puisque postmodernité ça
voudrait dire qu'on dépasse la modernité
qu'on peut on parle de post industrielle
là c'est concret puisque il ya une
remise en cause du mode de production
industrielle certes mais post modernité
c'est juste une accélération de la
modernité elle même c'est pas une
postmodernité
[Musique]